welcome to this video I'm playing fight
gallop fight club from the Ukraine and
GM I don't think I played it before
groups Russia GM so whatever yeah I
don't tell I don't have had in my
statistics so probably I really hadn't
played in before some rather unambitious
opening with c4 in b3 I'm going for a
double fianchetto you know it's a fairly
fairly solid position i think i just
take should should be a relatively easy
to play position setting up on head
shock type of type of game 1976 this
kind of moves ok mm-hmm quincy 8 is 95
has a bit a bit annoying mighty fire a
froakie age not be 50 came he's just
playing quickly I thought it was
interesting before I mean he can play it
and now it's not a problem but I thought
it would it was more more of a problem
earlier with 95 following I don't think
this should be should be a real problem
okay I can even think about e-cigs yeah
come on let's play six
Knight takes Knight takes Bishop takes
Queen takes its ok for black check ok
what is the point yeah well maybe just
overprotective six
is playing very quickly I can take
Quincy five so one possibility
okay was a simple simple way to play
hmm we are not sure if white still has
some some a charm black is okay the
structures always some structure always
looks like white should be a slightly
better but very often it it doesn't
really am it doesn't really show in the
practice yeah I'm just preparing g5 now
and this should equal is really
completely the only issue could be a
weakening or 36 square that sometimes as
a factor but I don't think this is the
case here I think we just trade stuff
and nothing happens ah now this is an
interesting move but I can play be five
right wait wait wait wait be five he can
yes this ideas of taking on b5 at the
end going to have six bits I know I
should be active enough the shouldn't
really be be an issue I'm talking about
moves like night XP five with with f6
hanging but i didn't i didn't calculate
this but i don't think it should be an
issue here thought just Queen takes
isn't this enough
it looked slightly tricky from a
technical point of here but didn't seem
to be a problem okay if I take the fat
to white but take f3 can you take ch no
not really done ok to take probably here
he's got the C file but I have half
counterplay might be for this one
possibility no should I go should I go
before and not really
yeah it's still a bit a bit annoying
with the sea fowl
with Bishop f8 I intend to always have
the a pawn attacked so that he cannot
easily move he on the queenside
mhm sure if I should have played before
it's not a move I like to play yeah I
know this does not really help but I
don't have a great idea at the moment
okay
yeah I don't let a killer drooly enter
here I completely misjudged the sea fowl
I can moan yeah
I have absolutely no play
maybe this one I should have played this
much quicker than a4a for Knight c3
intending 91 maybe other is still
something but let's see
maybe you should just take a six
took em take some some time at least
Wow what is he doing
come on no disconnecting I think he just
lost connection that's a shame it's very
an interesting position and after okay
six white is probably a much much better
yeah I think you outplayed me nicely in
this middle game yeah well it just takes
a one then I get the point you to
disconnection I guess yeah a bit of
shame on a four-night see three lights
for txt teachers can actually are very
very lucky affair if I am ya hear me she
can just take you and it is just the
pawn down and I porn up I can I can do
that and then try to try to fight i mean
i have some chances to fight the depot
at the moment cannot move but like a
some black is probably a lost if white
plays with excellent technique here
should g7 hour can maybe I'm too too
scared in this position and it's not so
terrible the computer is completely
unimpressed attests this move and then
aged six and g5 with equal play
hmm
age six and g5 in fact is really strong
I didn't really think about it because
so okay it's clear that this double porn
is not a big problem for white but the
thing is after g5 and the possible
capture I have more room for the King so
that in some positions i can even let's
say the rookies on see it i can even
consider to take on g7 and take on d4
with the bishop on g7 and that enter
with Roxy too because with age 65 played
I'm not mated on the back rank this is
an important point so this position is
probably not not so terrible as a salt
and then he did now play me you think
but around here look so here black can
play a fire with even a good game yeah
well it's a it's it's complicated here
route takes more stronger interesting no
but notice not it's not much i routed to
Claire Queen d2 interesting ace he's not
so well coordinated yeah maybe I should
have thought a bit more at this point I
just said okay let's get it over with
and tongue yeah yeah interesting a shame
that he disconnected i mean you hit what
would have been interesting to see if i
was able to hold the same game it
wouldn't have been much fun that's clear
okay thanks for watching